-Our first guest is
an Emmy-nominated actor,
who you can see in
the series "Modern Love,"
which is available starting
tomorrow on Amazon Prime Video.
Please welcome Kit Harington!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ It's Kit Harington,
this man's got the homes ♪
♪ As Jon on "Game of Thrones" ♪
♪ But on his new show,
no dragons from above ♪
♪ He's a romantic,
that show is "Modern Love" ♪
-Dude, you got --
That's Kit Harington.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Kit...
Kit, you've gotten two standing
ovations already tonight.
-I did not deserve it.
-I have to
thank you so much for doing
"Straight Up Goes For It,
Drops of Jupiter."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes!
What made you say yes to that?
-Yeah, I had a lot of thoughts
when you sent me that,
like, a lot.
And the sensible part of my
brain, the bit that said,
"You're not a singer,
you've no connection
to this song,
it's of no relevance to anything
you're talking about
on the show..."
-That's correct.
-...said, "Don't do it."
But there was another little
part of my brain -- right? --
the bit that gets me in trouble
that was like,
"But what if you're brilliant?"
[ Laughter ]
-Wow!
-Do you know what I mean?
-Wow. You're right.
-What if you're brilliant?
What if it opens up
whole new vistas
of a career in singing?
-Wow. That's interesting.
-Yeah.
-That could happen.
-The thing is, that
10 seconds before I started,
that same little part of
my brain said,
"You shouldn't have done this."
[ Laughter ]
-I just love it.
I just love that
you did it, man.
You're just a good man.
I love you, man.
I'll never forget that.
We were talking backstage, and I
said "congratulations" to you,
because you just recently
became a dad.
-Yeah.
-That's amazing.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Yes.
-That's a -- Congratulations.
-Thank you so much.
Yeah, we're thrilled.
He's lovely.
-How old is he?
-He's 6 months old.
-Oh, wow.
-So he's in that
gorgeous little stage.
And, yeah, it all came about
because we went into
the pandemic, you know, me
and Rose, thinking --
not knowing how long it
was gonna last,
but getting all kind of
apocalyptic and romantic,
and, you know,
then we got a baby.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
And, you know, no spoilers --
I will never do that
to anybody --
but did you get any advice
from other parents?
-So much advice.
Anyone who's a parent will know
you get so much advice
leading up to it,
and it's all useless.
It's all useless.
It's all stuff like,
"It's gonna be great.
You're going to love it.
What a wonderful thing."
They don't -- No one tells you
that, essentially --
at first, anyway -- what it is,
is you get, like,
a new roommate
just dumped into your life,
who you've not interviewed,
who doesn't know
any of the rules,
any of your house rules.
-Yeah, breaks all of them.
-Yeah, breaks
all your house rules.
And then you fall in love with
him, so you can't kick him out.
That's basically parenting,
I think.
-What's one of your favorite
parts of him?
-I just -- Do you know what?
I go in in the morning,
and he has this bright smile
and he's chuckling already
when I walk in the door.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
Yeah, I know.
-There you go. I mean, come on.
That's...
-But then he just dismantles
any plans I had for that day.
-Oh, yeah, of course. Yeah.
But do you make him laugh
and do anything?
You do anything to make
the kid laugh.
-I do anything.
Yeah, I think Rose is
the one who
he seems to respect and love,
and, like, she's his safe place.
And I'm just -- I just seem
to be sheer entertainment.
Do you know what I mean?
And not even
very good entertainment,
just entertainment, you know?
-Yeah, but just like --
What do you do, like --
-Oh, I've --
You know, I do anything.
I dance for him.
-Yeah.
I think --
Are you a good dancer?
-Oh, I used to be a good --
Well, I thought I used
to be a --
I also thought
I was a good singer.
-You are. No, you are.
-No, I used to be a good dancer,
but you sort of --
He -- I put him
in his little chair,
and he likes dancing to
The Beatles.
And so -- But he only likes it
if I do these exaggerated moves.
So I have to kind of really --
That's -- I've worked out where
the dad dance comes from.
-So, is that -- You do that?
-No, it's more --
it's more like...
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Dude, that's...
[ Laughs ]
Come on, bud.
-That's -- Yeah, but now --
Like, now I realize --
I go back onto a dance floor,
and I'll dance like that.
I've lost the
old moves entirely.
-Oh, how do --
-And then, in the future,
I know he's going to
mock me about it.
And I'll be like,
"This is your fault."
-Exactly.
"I did this is for you."
Well, you're here in New York
because you just --
You're filming a movie, right?
Right now. "Baby Ruby"?
-Yeah. I did a film upstate,
a beautiful little film
called "Baby Ruby,"
which I can't really
tell you anything about.
-That seems to be what
most of my interviews are now.
I have people come on,
and they're not allowed to
tell me about anything.
'Cause you're also in --
I think you can say this.
You're in the Marvel "Eternals."
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah. Thank you.
-That's out in November.
-Yeah.
-And you can't say
anything about that.
-It's -- I mean -- Yeah.
I seem to have
segued from a TV show
where I can't tell you anything
on to a movie where
I can't tell you anything.
-That's great. That's exactly --
-Could tell you how that TV show
ended now, if you want, but --
-No. I loved -- You know, I was
giant fan of "Game of Thrones."
But when you do a Marvel thing,
do they have lawyers
come into the room and be like,
"Hey, sign these papers, and
you don't even mess, like --"
-I just think it's an aura.
I think that there's a kind of,
like, you just know.
No one tells you.
No one says
you can't say anything.
Well, first of all,
they don't --
You know,
I didn't get sent a script.
I just got sent,
"This is who you're playing."
-Oh, really?
-Yeah.
And so I was like, "Okay."
So I just had to Google
the character.
This is, you know, a hell of
a way to kind of work out,
you know, who you're playing.
And --
-What did you find from Google?
-Well, I found out that he --
I Googled him and I was like --
He's a character called
Dane Whitman,
and I realized he has
a sword and rides a horse.
And I was like,
"I know this guy.
I've been this guy."
-"I've been this guy." Yeah.
"I've crushed this character."
Yeah.
-But, actually, he's quite
different, so it's exciting.
Yeah.
-And there was a rumor that
maybe Harry Styles is in this.
[ Crowd cheering ]
-I have no idea.
Unless I've been recast,
and he's playing my part,
I have not a clue.
-No. So you didn't
run into him or anything?
-No.
So you guys did
scenes separately?
-I -- Ooh!
[ Laughs ]
-Why would I try
to sneak something?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, I don't do that.
-No. No comment.
-Yeah.
But he's a
good guy though, right?
-Yeah, I hear
he's a great guy, yeah.
Yeah.
-Yeah, you would know, right?
I mean, you spent time
with the guy.
-Yeah. lovely.
Lovely chap, I think.
I don't know.
I've never met the guy.
[ Laughs ]
-See? You're a good actor,
so I don't know
what's happening right now.
Alright, I want to talk about
your series, "Modern Love."
Your episode is up --
Well, it's available tomorrow.
What drew you to this series?
-I just --
I loved the first season,
and, quite honestly,
it was something lighter to do,
lighter to play.
I'd spent nine years playing
a very serious character,
who had zero comedy
to him at all,
and I thought, you know,
this was --
-Imagine if Jon Snow was
supposed to be funny
in that show.
That would ruin the whole
"Game of Thrones."
-They tried every now and again.
They threw him a joke.
Just fell flat,
just did not work.
Did not work with him.
They got cut.
No, so, with "Modern Love," it's
just a beautiful little story
about two guys on --
Two people who meet on a train
on the way to Dublin.
And they sort of kind of
have this instant connection,
and then they
don't switch numbers.
And it's at the beginning
of the pandemic,
so they do it old school,
but they don't know
how long it's going to last.
And then, of course,
everything goes into lockdown,
and they've got no way
of finding each other.
So it's whether
they find each other,
and it sort of
raises some questions
about what we all did
in the lockdown
and where our moral lines lay
and legal lines and all that.
-It's shot in Ireland.
I'm assuming
that really was Ireland.
-It was, yeah.
-Okay. Yeah.
John Carney directed it,
and it's where he's from.
And, yeah, we were bunked up
in this little cottage,
quaranti-- We were quarantining
in this cottage,
and it was like being in some
sort of Amazon feedback loop.
-Amazon feedback?
-Yeah, well,
because, essentially,
we couldn't go anywhere,
so we were ordering
all our food off Amazon
to be arrived,
being paid by Amazon,
but the only thing they put on
the TV was Amazon shows.
So it was this kind of
circulating...
-Wow! That's a lot of Amazon.
-It's a terrifying glimpse
into the future.
-They're paying you,
but you're spending the money
they're paying you on --
-Yeah. I felt like
I'd been duped into it.
-♪ The circle of life ♪
Yeah. That's so good.
I want to show a clip.
Here is Kit Harington in
"Modern Love."
Take a look at this.
-Sorry. Uh, do you mind?
I'm just getting a crick
in my neck at this angle.
Is it okay if I, uh --
-Yeah. Sorry.
Go ahead.
♪♪
-Ahh! That's better.
What were you saying?
-Can't remember. Sorry.
Can I ask you a funny question?
-Sure.
-When you first got on, how come
you sat over there with her,
when you had the option of
the two tables?
-I just prefer to sit facing
the direction we're going in,
that's all.
-Yeah. Now you're sitting
the opposite way.
-Yeah, but I'm facing you.
So my neurosis
can take a back seat for a bit.
It's not a big thing,
just a little quirk.
It's not like it dominates
my life or anything.
-Do you want to swap seats?
-Yes.
-[ Laughs ]
That's a good time.
Kit Harington, everyone!
Season 2 of "Modern Love"
is available tomorrow on
Amazon Prime Video.